♪ ♪
>> Tucker: TIME NOW FOR A
FINAL EXAM, OUR QUESTIONS WILL
SEPARATE THE WEEK FROM THOSE WHO
HAVE BEEN PAYING ATTENTION TO
THOSE THAT HAVE NOT BEEN.
THIS WEEK, ELIZABETH PRANN WHO
UNDID PETER DOOCY AFTER HIS
SHORT REIGN.
HER CHALLENGER TONIGHT, A
FREQUENT TECH CORRESPOND.
DOES HE HAVE TIME TO PAY
ATTENTION?
WE'LL FIND OUT.
THE WINNER GETS THAT.
YOU KNOW THE RULES BECAUSE WERE
THE REIGNING CHAMPION, BRETT,
I'M SURE YOU'RE A WEEKLY VIEWER
OF THIS, BUT IN CASE THOSE OF
YOU WHO DON'T KNOW, HANDS ON
BOXERS, AS THE QUESTIONS.
THE FIRST ONE WHO BUZZES GETS TO
ANSWER, YOU HAVE TO WAIT UNTIL I
FINISH THE QUESTION.
EACH CORRECT ANSWER IS WORTH ONE
POINT, EACH AND CORRECT IT
ATTRACTS A POINT.
BEST OF FIVE WINS.
ARE YOU READY?
QUESTION ONE, WE ARE GOING TO
START WITH A COMPLEX ONE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS REVEALED HIS
OPENING FOR FORMER
PRESIDENT BARACK OBAMA.
IS THAT NICKNAME MR. NICE GUY
OBAMA, CRAFTY OBAMA, OR CHEATING
OBAMA?
>> I HAVE NO IDEA.
>> I'M GOING WITH CHEATING
OBAMA.
>> Tucker: IS MR. LARSON
CORRECT?
>> THANK YOU FOR THE HONEST POLL
THAT JUST HIT 50% WHICH IS
HIGHER THAN CHEATING OBAMA AT
THE SAME TIME.
>> Tucker: WHAT DOES THAT MEAN
MEAN?
>> I DID VERY WELL AND MULTIPLE
CHOICE IN HIGH SCHOOL.
>> Tucker: QUESTION TWO.
A CNN REPORTER WENT OFF THE DEEP
END THIS WEEK AND STARTED
YELLING IN FRONT OF KIDS AT THE
WHITE HOUSE EASTER EGG ROLL.
WHICH REPORTER WAS THAT?
>> JIM ACOSTA.
>> Tucker: CHIEF WHITE HOUSE
CORRESPONDENT AT CNN.
WAS IT?
>> CHIEF WHITE HOUSE
CORRESPONDENT JIM ACOSTA FACING
SOME BACKLASH FOR SHOVING
QUESTIONS ABOUT KILLING DACA AS
PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS COLORING
WITH HIS SON.
>> DIDN'T YOU KILL DACA?
>> Tucker: YOU'RE GUILTY OF
KILLING DACA.
>> IT CAN BE A VERY EMOTIONALLY
CHARGED EVENTS.
>> Tucker: ESPECIALLY WHEN
THERE IS A DACA MURDERER ON THE
LOOSE.
QUESTION THREE, ANOTHER
MULTIPLE-CHOICE.
SCIENTISTS JUST ANNOUNCED A
MAJOR RISK EVERY OVERSEAS.
FOOTPRINTS BELONGING TO MASSIVE
EXTINCT DINOSAURS, SOME AS LONG
AS 50 FEET WERE IN WHICH COUNTRY
AS 50 FEET WERE IN WHICH COUNTR
COUNTRY?
>> SCOTLAND.
>> Tucker: UTIL THINK IT WOULD
BE SWEDEN?
>> SCIENTISTS SAY THEY
DISCOVERED FOOTPRINTS IN
SCOTLAND.
49 FEET LONG, 10 TONS AND WEIGHT
49 FEET LONG, 10 TONS AND WEIGH
WEIGHT.
>> Tucker: I'M IMPRESSED.
WOW.
QUESTION FOUR, STEVEN SPIELBERG
SAYS HE MAY REBOOT, REMAKE ONE
OF HIS BIG 1980s FRANCHISES
AND CHANGE THE ICONIC MAY LEAD
TO A FEMALE.
WHICH WELL-KNOWN CHARACTER IS HE
TALKING ABOUT?
>> INDIANA JONES?
>> Tucker: URL FUEGO TONIGHT.
WAS IT INDIANA JONES OR ET?
>> STEVEN SPIELBERG SAYS IT'S
TIME FOR A WOMAN TO PLAY ONE OF
HIS MOST ICONIC MOVIE
CHARACTERS.
SPIELBERG BELIEVES INDIANA JONES
IS READY TO TAKE ON A NEW FORM
WHEN HARRISON FORD STEPS AWAY
FROM THE ROLE.
>> HOW WOULD THAT WORK?
>> Tucker: IT SHOULD HAVE BEEN
PHRASED "HAVING RUN OUT OF NEW
IDEAS."
FINAL QUESTION OF THE CONTEST.
THIS IS ONE OF THE WEIRDER
STORIES WE'VE EVER COVERED.
ZOMBIE-LIKE ANIMALS HAVE BEEN
TERRORIZING RESIDENTS IN THE
VALLEY OF OHIO STANDING ON THEIR
HIND LEGS BEARING THEIR TEETH.
THIS BEHAVIOR IS PRONE TO THE
POLICE INVESTIGATION.
WHICH TYPE OF ANIMAL HAS BEEN
SEEN WITH THE ZOMBIE LIKE
SYMPTOMS?
>> RACCOONS.
>> Tucker: I DON'T KNOW IF
THAT CAN BE RIGHT.
LET'S ROLL THE TAPE.
>> ZOMBIE RACCOONS.
RESPONSIBLE FOR MORE THAN A